why is it okay for women to feel
entitled to be protected and provided
for but it's wrong for a man to feel
entitled to sex and intimacy
[Music]
social social constructs isn't it i call
it
an [ __ ] question
if you say it if you ask it you become
an [ __ ] so
why haven't we had sex i want you to
lose weight suddenly you're the [ __ ]
for saying these questions
um i would say easy because law is
written masculine
so explain
so every if you look at the english law
if it was based on english law it's
written he
him
himself
um
so that double standards has
in terms of in terms of from the english
culture point of view
it's just organic i don't understand
what you're saying because a lot of the
laws like favor women i would say and
not men i would say like all laws
exactly so in terms of the prosecution
of it right it's based masculine so for
example a woman can't be accused of
grape right right yes no yes because
there's no penetration it's like he
penetrated
do you know what i'm saying yeah so
that's why that's where the double
standard comes in in the sense of whoa i
can do what you do and not get
prosecuted for it mm-hmm do say it in
the media it's wrong for you right but
okay for me mm-hmm
so
okay
um
no i just
what do you guys think why why is it um
why do we expect men
uh
i forgot what the question was oh yeah
why is it okay for women to feel
entitled to be protected and provided
for but it's wrong for a man to feel
entitled to sex and intimacy what do you
guys think
i think the question should be reframed
where
the
the men should be entitled to a woman
who submits to his leadership instead of
sex because then it's both more of an
emotional
um
currency between the two but then in
that case i don't think that is fair
yeah
i i don't think
anyo is entitled to anything no one
really owes you anything yeah yeah
because at the end of the day
um a man shouldn't be entitled to have
sex with any woman they want
because it's a woman's body and no woman
should be entitled to be protected by a
man because at the end of the day if
they're a woman just because they're a
woman yeah but if you're in a
relationship
if you're married if you're in a
relationship if you're married oh my god
if i was married and a robber came in
yeah here
that's true but then you go back to
in the relationship
i think he would be entitled to sex if
he's married
he will be entitled to sex but would you
feel you need to give it to him all the
time yes
even if you don't want it yeah it's a
you show up to your job and you don't
want to that's your job your wife that's
a very that's a very good comparison
i mean like sure you can have a sick day
like but you only get so many sick days
a year before you start counting your
days i heard that
i hear that question is i don't know if
she's like
i hear that why is it you just suddenly
stop wanting sex the other one wants it
so one of you is well i i think it's
because a lot of women marry their
second choice and so it's not actually
someone they want they just you know
they got the kids and now they're good
would you say would you say a lot of
women are entitled what to be protected
yeah
um
to some extent yeah and but i will go
back to like
being a woman
and looking at the type of woman who
they are kind of thing and i would say
as a woman there are some women that
don't really do much in their
relationship they don't do no effort
and you feel like you actually have got
a good guy
and
why do you think you're entitled to have
all of these things and you're not
bringing up the table and it's not just
about sex because this is the other
thing are women just to design to have
sex is that all they can bring to the
relationship if is it just front and
that's it it's because then that's the
problem it's it's not just sex but if
you don't have sex guys don't want to
get married that's like a big reason
they get married like if you told dude
okay there's no sex involved
they're not they're not getting people
you have to get married to have sex
that's the thing you can get sex
anywhere you don't need to go through
that that thing about i need to get
married but what paul's saying is that
if you're in a relationship the woman
expects the man to stay with that one
woman but then the man is not allowed to
expect that woman to always want to have
sex with him
like and especially especially with the
big risk that men take today
because men take such a big risk if they
get married because you can leave take
half and take their kids
that's a lot of that's a lot of power to
give a woman but they wouldn't so if
they're if they're willing to do that
it's like
hell give just give him sex when he
wants
so what if a man has um an accident or
something happened to him and what is he
still expected to protect that woman the
same way he before that accident isn't
it is he exactly it's a different type
of protection isn't it doesn't always
have to be physical financial
and that's why
men think that it's all about money but
really a woman cares equally much about
his mindset of being a provider than how
much he actually makes because there's
men who make you know multiple six
figures and they don't believe in
being a provider and then there's also
men who make 50k a year but they have
that provider and they have good
leadership skills and they have good
levels of integrity good levels of
communication et cetera
with money because money is just money
money can come money can go well it's a
big part
i think i think it's competence that
women are more attracted to than money
it's like it's a guy that's smart and
that tends to go with money but if you
could win the lottery tomorrow he's not
hot yeah like money is just a byproduct
of the traits that you have it's the
mindset around the money as well i think
i watched a youtube video and it wasn't
having money it was the ability to make
it yes and that's what they found
attractive
yeah it's like you find it more
attractive if a guy has money lost it
and then made it again yeah because it
shows resilience or something yeah
but like you could i mean i i would if a
dude won the lottery he's not hot to you
and as soon as the money goes you will
be too
you wouldn't trust anything he does it
was all based on luck yeah
yeah
that's but that's it's i wouldn't say
that's to do the money that's to do with
the person not being honest
and that's the person not being honest
in all aspects it's just because money
has been the factor of what he's lying
about but if a person can't communicate
about being honest you know what this
happened you know lost my job couldn't
help with the house couldn't do this
that's communication so the issue is not
to do with how much money he's got and
the money he has it's the issue that
he's not able to say do you know what
this has happened and this is the truth
that's the problem
might be a tangent but
with women going off to make their own
money does that make is that the reason
why money has become so important no
women might have to make their own money
because we're living in the time where
petrol is nearly two pounds everyone has
that's the issue but it's nothing to do
with oh i better make the money because
i need to be
the man of the house because i'm not a
man
but that's basically what it is but the
problem is it would be not because oh
he's got money now and he's not got
money so i'm going i've got a problem
because you couldn't come to me as my
man as me being your woman to say this
is what the issue is because
what how they look at relationship the
man is the head and i'm the neck so
basically you forgot that i was a nick
to support you
and it all goes back to ego
so i mean and that's what needs to
really kind of dismiss and go and that's
how relationship i believe couldn't work
well i think a lot of women think
they're better than guys when they make
more money than them that's ego yeah but
yeah but it's like
you're you're not as many of you know i
was just banned on tick tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible